-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
According to a new report,
the Justice Department
was prepared to obtain a warrant
if President Biden did not agree
to last week's search
of his Delaware home.
Oh, he's not the kind of guy
who won't let you in.
He's the kind of guy
who won't let you leave.
"Come on, guys."
[ Laughter ]
"One more Michelob.
I'm gonna get out my guitar."
New York Mayor Eric Adams told
reporters yesterday
he does not believe asylum
seekers
should qualify
for the same protections
that require the city to provide
shelter to homeless people.
In related news,
the Statue of Liberty
walked into the Hudson River.
[ Laughter ]
New York Congressman
George Santos
gave his first floor speech
yesterday
and quoted former President
Ronald Reagan,
or as Santos calls him, "Dad."
[ Laughter ]
"My living dad."
Former President Trump has
reportedly begun texting.
This news first reported
by Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ] Throwback.
Trump has already reportedly
stopped picking up calls
from numbers
that are not in his contacts,
which is surprising
since you'd think he'd jump
at the chance to pick up
a call that says "scam likely."
[ Laughter ]
"I think you and I are going to
have a lot in common..."
[ Laughter ]
"...Scam Likely."
[ Chuckles ]
Transportat--
That was
his Secret Service name.
[ Laughter ]
The Transportation Department
has announced
that it is in the early stages
of its investigation
into Southwest Airlines'
handling of flight cancelations
during last month's
holiday season...
and should be done by the time
everyone makes it home.
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that Earth's inner core
may have stopped turning
and could go in reverse.
Shouldn't have
gotten the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
A passenger on an Emirates
flight to Dubai
recently gave birth midflight.
Not to be outdone, a passenger
on Spirit...got pregnant!
[ Laughter, applause ]
I just used a technique called
Amy Poehler-ing the punch line.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
in Connecticut
are looking for a thief
who recently stole
two designer bags
and a hairless cat,
or as the thief believed,
three designer bags.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh [no audio]"
[ Hissing ]
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're off!
We're off and running!
[ Cheers and applause ]